yes to your point are women better at
some things than men yes for example if
you and I were to box I would probably
win but I can almost guarantee you that
you can suck [__] better than I can
what do you not have a mouth it's the
same mouth that you're going to use if
you're going to suck [__] isn't it so
who's it what I'm saying
the same mouth
okay
I have a conversation and be mature I
have a bottom lip and I have a top lip
and I have a tongue so do you so if you
want to suck [__] you go ahead and do
that I'm not gonna compete with you now
if you don't want to have a mature
conversation I'm being mature
I don't know how we went from domestic
abuse
that's just the city
it's immature